so he lives in India and he is a one-man
company that makes something between 15
and 30 million dollars selling simple
plugins for Google Docs if you if you
have 20 million dollars a year of income
that is a huge unheard of song
[Music]
all right we live what's going on all
right I got a couple interesting things
for you
um I'm gonna start with this one-man
company so I gotta I saw a tweet I got
tagged in a tweet a bunch of times same
the exact same one
and I think we should talk about this
because this was very is it the Google
plug-in guy
yes yeah so all right so this guy John
David's uh tweeted out a great thread
and his handle is real real John David
So shout out to him for doing this and
he's basically like dude I discovered
this guy and let me just tell you some
things about this guy so how funny is it
that something like this happens and I I
know exactly what you're talking about
because we I got DM the amount the same
people probably DM to me well that's
when you know you're doing a good job
when people see something and they think
of you
um I tweeted this out I go people think
you create content like a podcast or a
YouTube channel to become well known
right oh you want fame you want to
become well known and
some people want that and there is some
benefits to that but that's not my goal
with this stuff my goal is to be known
well which means people know you really
well that means when they see something
they'll know to send it to you they'll
show it to you they'll share it with you
they'll invest it where they'll tell you
to come invest in this deal with them
when you're known well it's because
you've put your brain out there on blast
people know how you think and so when
they see something that they know you'll
love they immediately think of you and
they come share it with you and so I
would say the even if you create content
and you're never famous it never takes
off and you become well known you will
become known well and that alone is a
big enough benefit to justify uh
creating content all right anyway so
we're known well because these uh a
bunch of people tagged Us in this this
guy so
this guy uh what is his name so his
name's Amit Agarwal so he lives in India
and he is a one-man company that makes
something between 15 and 30 million
dollars
selling simple plugins for Google Docs
and Google Drive and the Google the G
Suite of apps this is crazy that that is
that is that is dude making if you if
you have 20 million dollars a year of
income that's like the equivalent of I
would have to think about this and maybe
someone who's thought about this is
going to say I'm an idiot and I'm
getting it wrong but making 20 million
dollars a year in income is probably the
same as being worth like
500 million dollars
uh lifestyle wise it definitely is like
it's a huge that is a huge unheard of
song
so this guy basically he's a he goes to
IIT which is like the Harvard of of
India he's a computer science guy he
moves back to his hometown so he goes to
the big city comes back to his hometown
and in 2004 he starts off as like a tech
blogger he's just writing tips and
tricks on how to use G suite and he
creates a Gmail plugin that lets you do
what's called a mail merge a mail merge
is basically like you want to email 100
people the same thing but not in one
group email and not even as a BCC
because you want to customize some
component yeah I'm a customer of this
product
and so he created a plug-in that just
lets you do that in Gmail because
there's a lot of services that will let
you do that outside of Gmail but like a
lot of you just want to run it inside
their inbox and not like use some
third-party app to send send emails so
it creates this thing and that's how I
think his biggest hit but he just starts
writing go like you know how-to guides
on his website this website's called
digital inspiration and so it'll be like
you know how to calculate the percentage
score in a Google form how teachers can
email your parents the uh email parents
using Google forms or something like
that and it's free but then he has like
a paid tier 39 a year 79 a year to get
rid of like The Branding and stuff like
that email you know go past a limit of
emails something like that and so his
main mail merge thing has been
downloaded seven and a half million
times and so if you assume like a you
know five percent conversion rate to
paid he's doing 1.5 million in ALR just
off of that one plug-in and he's got 13
more plugins so he's got like his whole
set of things he's got this document
management app called document studio
and it lets you create documents
certificates invoices using Google
Sheets and it's 79 million a year six
million downloads he's got a
notification app 49 a year he's got 10
million downloads he's got a YouTube app
8 million downloads and then he creates
one-off apps for big companies like
Airbus LinkedIn Disney even the US
Embassy has paid this guy to create
custom G Suite things just for them like
if you kind of blend this all together
you start doing some estimates like I I
DM the guy I was like hey can you
confirm what the numbers I don't want to
say the wrong number but I'm going to
tell the story on the Pod he didn't he
didn't reply yet but he um it's pretty
safe to say this guy's doing more than
10 million a year and it could be as
high as 25 30 million if you're like
really aggressive with how much he's
getting from the Enterprise customers
and but somewhere between 10 and I'd say
25 million is a fairly safe bet how does
he have and I see a lot of simple useful
things he had a hundred thousand
followers on Instagram is he famous for
some reason like what what's because a
guy like this seems under the radar I
think his Blog has a good amount of uh
traffic so I'm gonna go open up his blog
yeah so this blog gets about 150 000
hits a month uh visitors a month and so
I think he probably just says hey this
is made by B and then people go follow
him or something what's the uh tax rate
in India do you know is it comparable to
America or is it way worse or way better
I don't know but I think I remember
hearing at one point that only two
percent of the Indian population paid
taxes really the majority of the
population just simply didn't pay taxes
this is a big problem in India because
they're not banked either so it's like
there's no way to track anything cash
economy you don't have a bank account
it's like there's like not exist yeah
taxes no it's not for me yes optional uh
but I think that might have changed this
was like 10 years ago I heard that stat
and I was like what the hell uh so I'm
sure that's changed over time dude what
a baller you know this is so great I
think that the reason it's great is
because it kind of breaks your frame on
what's possible because he's like when
you're in Google Docs there's so many
times where I'm like man I wish I just
do this one thing there's just this one
very very specific thing and I would
never think this should be a product
because
I'm like it's just me experiencing one
tiny issue that if I learned how to
program or learn how to do like uh this
other thing it would work perfectly fine
in this little you know thing is only
gonna save me five minutes it's not a
big deal but this is a good example of
that
um
that's sick I use some of his products
they're really good
by the way now that the paying rate I
think is six percent of the population
filed the tax return
in uh when was this this was
2020. so you think wow well good for
this guy hopefully he's one of the 94
percent
even if he is dude if you have like a
million dollars in India like you're a
king
um you know you don't need that much
money to just ball out and small towns
in India like you are set
well I like this guy what's the uh who's
Carl Allen all right this is my Billy of
the week
[Music]
[Applause]
it's cool a billion dollars
[Music]
this story is kind of incredible also
came to me from a um a Twitter DM
um the guy's name is kind of like hard
to it's not like his real name I want to
give him credit but like you know I
don't know what to what to call him his
his uh Twitter handle is Euro reppe
r-e-p-e so Euro repay he goes I got
ability of the week for you Carl Allen
he goes sold a garbage bag company this
one too this is so funny I got the exact
same one a full-time treasure hunter in
the Bahamas okay so who is this guy you
know like the uh I don't know if you
watch Game of Thrones but in Game of
Thrones it's like um A Song of Ice and
Fire this is a song of garbage and
treasure this is this guy basically is
kind of an insane story it's very hard
to even find information about this guy
I don't know if you looked him up but I
did a lot the only thing like they
didn't cover his business they covered
the fact that he was buying like a huge
yacht
so all right so so here's what I do know
all right so Carl Allen he basically he
starts off working at this company
called Heritage bag and Heritage bag
makes plastic trash bags so like they do
it not just like normal trash bags but
like for medical waste or like Hospital
waste but they'll make like anything
that's like uh you know ice bucket
liners
um you know like they'll make take out
boxes anything that's like mass
production manufacturing for for like
this really core utility very similar to
like egg cartons.com the the story that
we told on the Pod before and so medical
waste bags is their thing he actually
started off just like working there he
worked kind of like it's like one of
those stories we worked his way up from
the mail room he had like one job then
he climbed up then he got into business
development then became the Director of
Business Development then eventually he
becomes the CEO and eventually he buys
the company and I don't know how he
pulled this off I tried to find this I
could not find how this employee ended
up owning the company but he did he ends
up owning the company and it's a boring
business based in Dallas you know
selling trash bag and he sells it for
something like 300 or 400 million
dollars to I think a private Equity Firm
so they've they've got 800 employees
they've been around for 30 40 years
something like that and they sell and um
and so they you know they do this and
then he's like all right what do I do
with my life now and at the age of 12 he
had visited the Bahamas and he was like
wow I love the Bahamas this is just a
magical place they always have this idea
and so he he looks at this place that um
this island and he calls up the owner
and he's like hey
um you know are you would you ever be
interested in selling they're like no
we've been asked before we won't sell
this thing it's a 92 year old woman
she's like no we won't sell it to some
big Corporation that's just going to
ruin it he goes no no ma'am I'm not a
big Corporation I'm a family guy I'm a
family owner I'm just a rich guy
I'm just a guy with a handful of yachts
and I need a place to park them and
basically he convinces this woman to
sell they sell 50 years after they had
originally bought it he buys this island
he turns it into like his own little
fishing boating and exploring place so
he's got now three parts of his business
he's got philanthropy he's got his
family office where he invests and now
he's got his Island business his
yachting business his fishing business
and he owns a handful of Yachts he's got
like I think it's called an 80-foot
yacht he calls it an exploration
business
well he's got his yeah he's got his
exploration business but I think he also
calls his investing his expert from his
I don't know it's a little confusing but
Allen exploration I think is is one of
them but either way go to his YouTube
channel did you watch any of his YouTube
videos he's sick yeah the guys the guy's
amazing
[Music]
a dream of sailing the sea
the life with the ones he loves
discovering all the world has to offer
a dream of exploration
[Applause]
[Music]
it only has 41 000 views
41 000 views and it's basically his
channel where he is he believes that
there are billions of dollars of Lost
Treasures in the sea he's like there
have been three million shipwrecks he's
like and when something is Lost at Sea
it's not lost it's just at the bottom
like he's like it's still there it
didn't go anywhere it's still there and
we just have to go find it and he did
this because he met some guy who's a
treasure hunter who had made millions of
dollars finding Treasures in the ocean
and he was fascinated by this guy and
he's like let's do this I want to do
this and so he started doing this and
he's looking for like these Treasures
where it's like King Philip from Spain
had this like you know Armada coming
over and it got lost at sea back in the
whatever you know the year 1200 or
whatever and he's like we gotta go find
that because there were these like crazy
gold things and whatever and he wants to
create a museum of the things that he
finds and he's found a bunch of
treasures he found this long gold chain
he's found like all kinds of stuff down
there and he puts it in his little
Museum on his island in the Bahama and
it's just like and it's a public it's a
private island I mean he owns it but he
keeps it open to the public it's not
like nobody can come and so people can
come they can visit they can park their
boats there all that stuff so isn't this
kind of amazing like what a dope life
this guy is living it's this is amazing
for a couple different reasons one it's
so fun to give in to these obsessions so
you say like well what's the point of
spending your life looking for Treasure
It's like because it's sick because it's
awesome right like it's exciting that's
an exciting chase you should do that and
it is actually I'm sure there's some
like historical value I actually had a
guy send me a pitch deck on investing in
his like hunt and I was like no I'm not
even gonna no way yeah I was like not
not a chance like I don't know anything
about this this sounds like this of
course this sounds intoxicating and I
love it but like I have to avoid that
but number two I've been thinking about
this phrase
um make the make 12 year old me make 12
year old say I'm proud and because I
remember like making some money and I
remember someone being like and I like
was fretting over like doing one thing
or the other thing and it was an awesome
thing but I was like it cost too much
and someone's like yeah but it's sick
like it's awesome like what what like
you know if when you were 12 this is
what you always wanted to do and I'm
like you're right why am I being such a
boner I should just do this thing and
and now like I do think that's a good
life motto which is like whatever 12
year old you wanted not all things but
some things you got to give in to those
indulgences and this guy is awesome I'm
a big fan of this well we get this
question a lot oh what would you go back
and tell your 20 year old self right
well if you were 21 again what advice
would you give your 21 year old self and
you hate that question I know you I hate
that question because I say no they say
if you had a start over again what would
you do and I'd be like I would have done
the same thing because that's what I'm
skilled at that's what I'm good at you
want you want me to give you an easy
answer like I don't know what you're
good at right and so you're like that's
the question people always ask but I I'm
with you I want the opposite which is
what advice ice would your 21 year old
self give you because it's very easy to
lose the plot the older you get the more
responsible you get the more practical
you get the more like you get lower
energy less risk all that stuff and
there's a conversion of you that's like
I don't know if it's 12 year old or the
21 year old but in either case that like
the goal was to have the most fun and do
awesome things and it wasn't thinking
about like how to save for retirement
that's not it wasn't on your mind back
then and so I think that for most people
the risk is not that they're playing
life too risky it's that they're playing
life way too safe and that the 12 year
old view or the 21 year old view you
would look at yourself and be like oh
man I grew up and I got kind of lame
oh damn like I'm just kind of like this
out of shape guy who complains a bunch
and like you know it's like saving money
for when they're even older like dude
you're already old and so like you know
I think that for most people they
actually need to go the other way they
need to have more fun they need to live
more childlike they need to have just
more silliness fun adventure in their
life and they need to take a little more
risk and play less safe
um I would say that that is the majority
of people and actually people treat it
like it's the opposite they think I need
they think that the they think the
advice is you need to be responsible if
you play it safer right life needs to be
more serious and it's like no actually
life needs to be way less serious have
you ever seen uh that one of the very
it's about 10 years old so it was one of
the early viral YouTube videos and this
this guy he's in his 30 at this point in
his 40s he when he was eight he recorded
himself saying hey Jonah what's going on
and he he's like as an eight-year-old
anticipated that he wanted to make a
video in his 30s where he was going to
have a conversation with himself and
it's you know older and is now at the
time 30s Jonah having a conversation ate
Jonah he's like hey what's going on
Jonah and he's like are you still
playing with this and he like held up a
toy and he was like and the older Jonah
was like no I'm not and he's clearly sad
and the younger drone was like because
you really love doing this and we love
drawing it and we love reading cartoons
about this and right now I think I want
to grow up and be a cartoonist where I
talk about this and the older Jonah's
like oh man I I kind of like quit doing
that when I didn't have time but I
actually still love it and it this video
went viral and I believe it kind of
kicked off his career where he was able
to start making movies and cartoons like
he used to be into and I whenever I
watched that video I get inspired I'm
like what would when I was eight like
what would you say like whoa you said
you're gonna do this why aren't you
right and I and I actually I don't think
the answer is you do what the 12 year
old you wanted to do because maybe 20 12
year old you just wanted certain dumb
things or only knew about certain things
but it's more like
if I was just explaining this to the 12
year old me would they not and be like
okay that's dope I didn't know that
hopefully you know that's crazy but like
that makes a lot of sense like that
sounds awesome that sounds fun versus
like just do what the children wants and
I think you're you're absolutely right
that like
people in general the happiest people
are the ones who are most childlike do
you want to do what are the traits of a
child a child is generally very curious
about the world they don't just like
think that they know it all right
um a child is generally like looking to
have fun they're looking to play not
just work and grind right like you know
like this I've never heard a 12 year old
on that grind set you know like tell
everyone's looking to play they're
looking to have a blast and like guess
what that's what you should be trying to
do too and um and so you know everything
I think about like if I went back to the
to the 13 year old me and I was like
dude this is our wife and they'd be like
what it's like yeah like yeah we get to
be with her like she she likes me and
then and he would be like oh dude
awesome like this is wow this turned out
amazing that would be like something I
would brag to my 13 year olds up like
dude we pulled this like that would be
so sick you get to have sex
exactly
like yeah dude it it happened
hahaha
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better you want to
do this last one uh yeah okay so last
one I wanted to do was an update on
Sarah's list okay so for those who are
new to the pod
back I don't know how long ago was this
like a year ago only a year ago I was in
New York yeah it was a year
so let me go look at this video so we
did a a video it's on YouTube September
7th oh almost exactly September 17th
2021 is September 19th today wow so two
you know basically a year to the day
um we did this thing 12 startups where
stock grants can make you a millionaire
and this was inspired by your wife uh
Sarah who basically was a self-made
millionaire and we said oh how'd she do
it did she invent the next big thing did
she make this crazy investment that paid
off and you're like no she's just like
worked at good companies and like a good
job not she wasn't CEO or c-suite yeah
she was a normal job normal job at a
good tech company and like yeah like
think about it this way like you know
they give you uh a job offer that will
pay you you know let's say 50k just to
use round numbers 50k a year in stock
compensation so you maybe you make 150
then you get 50 of stock so over four
years you got 200k of stock
well if that company goes up 5x and
valued during those four years which
many tech companies do it's a million
dollars of stock that you got cheese
and a lot of these companies will give
you like maybe a hundred thousand
dollars a year in stock and it's
airbnb's case that I don't know what it
went up but I think it probably went up
five or six times I don't remember
and your wife had done this at Facebook
she worked at Facebook she worked at
Airbnb did she work on another one or
were those she worked in everlane but I
don't think they've had an exit yet
and so uh she had done this and I was
just like kind of and it's also like
dude those were obvious it's not like
she was like oh she was one of the first
10 employees at Airbnb it's like no she
joined an Airbnb had how many employees
it was like hundreds if not thousands
right no it was I I think it was a
either 900 or a thousand it was six
years ago maybe so they they weren't new
and do you remember the valuation at
that time like roughly I think it was
18.
I think it was 18 billion and when they
ipo'd at the peak I think it was worth
110.
okay yeah 100 billion so let's say 5x
there
um at that Peak and so anyway so she had
done this and I just thought that was
amazing I thought this is like the most
underreported story in like you know
podcasts or Tech news or well you're
missing one of the things about this
you're missing one of the big Parts was
the reason it's underreported is it's
not that unique you know there's
thousands of people who work here
there's hundreds of thousands of people
who collectively work at maybe it's
Millions actually millions of people who
work these types of gigs by the way
she's not a programmer either she's not
like an engineer and there's not like
some barrier that you needed oh I can't
do it I don't know how to code I can't
work in a tech company no she's a
non-technical person she's skilled but
she's non-technical totally at a tech
company and so anyways we were like we
basically made a list called Sarah's
list which was what are the what are the
Dozen companies that we would bet on
today that we think if you just went you
got that job you got that stock package
that's worth let's say a quarter million
dollars today that that can Forex it
could turn into a million dollars
over your four-year vest so we're gonna
recap this and see how we did yes so I
have the numbers great idea I have the
numbers here
so I'm going to read you the companies
and then I'm going to read you uh where
we were right where we were wrong
because one of the companies on here
just got acquired so the reason this
came up was figma just got Acquired and
figma was on our list it was number
seven on our list they weren't in order
it was just like one of the ones we
listed and figma got acquired just now
for 20 billion dollars and when we had
done the the thing figma was at 2
billion so that was a 10x was it really
yeah figma was that two billion leader
like uh late like 12 months later it got
valued at um uh or sorry in between it
had also gotten valued at 10 billion so
it kind of depends on the timing but
when we did the Pod the last known
valuation was 2 billion I believe wow
and so um that was their series D and so
so yeah so basically that's a 10x from
where we were at so you go get that 200
000 uh you know stock package which is
now sitting on yeah and invest over four
years so a 200 000 stock package is
fifty thousand dollars a year which is
incredibly reasonable for that's like a
yeah more like an entry level that's
table seven Junior position there
whereas you can get 100K a year so you
might have had 400k in total stock
that'd be 4 million that you're sitting
on for me it's so hard to make four
million dollars in cash like it is not
that easy and this is one of the like
you know easier ways to do it so um so I
think that's kind of underrated
all right so let me give you the
companies on the list we had flexport
zapier uniswap and daril the defense
company replit the developer tools
company but the developer uh company
airtable
figma Rippling open store Fair next
health and one trust okay so those are
the companies now I'm going to read you
where they were at and where they're
where they are where they are now
um out of the 12 I'll just tell you
right now that all but
two of them I believe all but two of
them are up
um and the other two it's just they
haven't raised another round so we don't
know but there's reason to believe where
they might be up one uniswap might be
down just because crypto has like gone
down in total value
um so you unisop might be down but uh
only zapier and uniswap are not marked
up so already you're up if you're if
you're in any of these and zapier's not
marked up because they their whole
shtick is they don't want to raise
they're like we bootstrapped we raise
this one round of funding we're not
racing anymore until we go public
exactly so you're still likely up it's
just not marked okay so flexport when we
had done it it was at three billion it's
now at 8 billion so almost a 3X markup
um okay zapier in Juno swap we talked
about okay Andrew when we talked about
it was a 4.6 billion now it's at 6.6 so
not not a huge markup but you're up you
know whatever fifty percent
um
replica when we had done it
um when we had talked about it I think
the last known valuation at that time
was 200 million
it raised again at 800 million uh I
invested in that round so I and and so I
know that it's actually worth more today
because I get emails and phone calls
from these groups that are trying to buy
my replica stock they're like hey we are
willing to buy five million dollars up
to five million dollars of your riplet
stock and so I think that replits
probably valued today on the open market
more than 800 million but that's the
last one they they've known at so at
least a 4X markup likely more like 8X is
my guess on replit
um airtable air table was at 2 billion
when we did it 2.3 it's now at 11. so a
5x 5x jump on on air table
um figma we just talked about 2 billion
now it got bought for 20. so 10x
um Rippling Rippling was 6 billion when
we talked about it it's now at 11. so
double
open stores 250 million when we talked
about it and that was the only exception
it was the one that was lowest when we
talked about it uh as a valuation it's
now at 750 million dollars what was it
what was it when we started
250.50 wow 750.
um Fair Fare was at 7 billion it's now
at 12.5 so a little under double
um next Health was at 400 million now
it's at a billion so a little more than
double two and a half X
and one trust was at 2.7 billion now at
5 billion uh 5.3 billion so another
another 2X
pretty good we do good yeah all right
good deal get where's my Larry David
Cliff pretty good it's pretty pretty
pretty pretty pretty pretty
good pretty good keep in mind we've made
these predictions at the beginning of
like the best Tech bowl Market not of
all time but a really good one so a lot
of these valuations could be completely
nonsense you know like at that time we
could have thrown at a dartboard and
picked 10 random startups and the
likelihood that they wouldn't raises and
and now it's down but the valuations
I've given you are The Afters are all
2022 valuations wow all right so a few
takeaways one
exponential growth hard to completely
understand like thinking like can this
two or three or four x for most people
myself included it's a it's an exercise
to understand read the figma read the
figma revenue numbers you have those
right
I I don't know if I can well they're
publicly available oh they're they're
out when this deal came out they came
out all right keep talking and now find
it
okay so basically
uh you're right exponential growth is
like astounding and so you look at these
companies I've talked about this before
where
um when we were getting acquired we had
a chance to get Discord stock and I was
like oh discord's value at 2 billion wow
already at 2 billion it's like what
would we need to believe for first take
this deal it's like well we need to
think that it's going to get over 6
billion I don't know its last evaluation
was 15 billion so even me who's in the
in the industry in the space I am a tech
investor it's just hard to Fathom these
companies becoming worth not just
billions but tens of billions not just
tens of billions but even up to 100
billion in value that is just very very
hard to Fathom here's figma's growth and
the reason why this is astounding is
because I heard what their valuation was
which was 10 billion I thought that is
ridiculous I heard these numbers right
and then I thought huh that's actually
not that crazy so in 2017 they started
charging customers in 2018 they're at
4.1 million in Revenue in 2019 18 23
million 2020 77 million 2021 100 million
and check this out
2022 goal and they're on Pace to hit it
450 million dollars so in the course of
six years they went from zero to 450
million dollars in very recurring sticky
sticky Revenue like and their product
does everything they just look at some
of those jumps what were the first jumps
so it goes zero then it goes from zero
to one so two or four
twenty so here's the order 4 25 75 and
then this sucked a hundred and then
450 100 to 450 is astronomical that is
huge
yeah I think there's the there's like a
a thing and SAS that SAS investors look
for it's called triple triple double
double I don't know if you've seen this
but basically they like triple triple
double triple tripled well they did more
than a trouble they did from four to
twenty something that's 5x so they did
more than a triple then they did 20 20
to 75 25 to 75 or whatever they did a
triple for five five triple and then
they did double
and then they did another double then
they did a another 4.5 it's just kind of
insane it's crazy so and I'll obviously
helped by like you know remote work
because you like figma is basically like
a tool for designers and product people
to share designs
um like you know a designer will send me
a mock-up I add my comments I can move
stuff around I could see their Mouse
Moving it's almost like we're working on
the same thing together right next to
each other even though we're miles and
miles apart and uh and by the way
Amazing Story this is also another teal
Fellowship uh win and so it's crazy this
guy started this thing when he was 21
years old like 19 20 21 years old and um
you know has been building this there
was like a five-year build up where they
didn't make any Revenue he was just
building the product slowly but surely
and then got to a private beta and then
a public beta and then finally started
charging people you know I think the
company was founded like 2011 and then
it started making money in 2017.
even if I had this idea there is no way
five years later I'm still doing this
idea in the middle of that by the way
there was the Ico boom in in crypto in
2017. you know guess where my head would
have turned I'd been like oh whoa I
should be doing that over there right in
between then there's like you know just
waves and waves of other interesting
exciting sexy things that and he just
didn't take his eye off the ball they
just kept going kept building and they
won so the two more things that I hardly
understand the the first one I said was
it's hard to understand exponential
growth number two
it always seems late so if I bet a lot
of reactions if we go and read the
comment section was this seems
overvalued this is already too big you
know there's no Meetup left on this bone
it always seems too late and that goes
back to exponential growth it's hard to
understand so like if I told you like
your home that you're in right now might
be worth 10 million dollars in 20 years
you'd be like there's no way and you say
well that's just like you know four
percent growth for the next 20 years and
it's already grown four percent for the
trailing 50 years like okay I understand
logically but like when you say that
number it's quite hard to understand and
the last thing which is every startup we
named
it's not like they are unknown it's all
pretty obvious you if you Googled
best startups to work at I bet you six
of the 12 that we named were on some
type of list
um and granted we're not playing with
our lives here we're just naming 12
things and we got 10 out of 12 right you
know like uh if you're in that 11th or
12th one that might stink but like we're
not that smart we're 7.5 out of 10 in
terms of Industry knowledge and uh we
got it like it wasn't that hard
yeah totally and so I think uh I think
there's a couple couple other takeaways
with this too which is you said you said
it right
um it's really easy to think you're too
late on these Tech winners and what I
would say is when there's actually a
tech winner when that when they actually
have the fundamentals they have a great
product and they're winning in the
market and their growth rate is like you
know real
uh these things can get a lot bigger
than you think I remember reading when
Facebook got valued at 15 billion by
Microsoft and they had like no Revenue
at the time very or they had like I
don't know maybe
a few hundred million in Revenue but it
wasn't like uh
it just seemed like how big is this
social network thing going to be and
like
if somebody at that time was saying and
I'm sure there were a few people but
something that I'm saying yeah this is
going to end up being a trillion dollar
company I'd be like there's no is there
such a thing as a trillion dollar
company that's insane right like I've
told the story before one of the biggest
mistakes I made one of the worst
Investments I made was an investment I
made right and that means I invested in
Tesla and Tesla was at 2 billion and I
put all the money I had straight out of
college I put it into Tesla at 2 billion
and I wrote it up till it was at 7
billion or something like that and I
cashed out a 3X
and I remember at the time thinking okay
General Motors and these other whoever
the biggest ones at the time I think
they were at 20 something billion maybe
they're 25 billion I don't remember the
exact numbers but something like that
and I was like one day Tesla could be
you know half as big or maybe even as
big as those companies it just seemed
like that was the roof that was the
ceiling on how big these could be and
then Tesla went up and became at one
point a trillion dollar company now it's
come back down to like you know whatever
half but um
my 2 billion could have been become a
trillion basically in terms of what
would you have made do you think how
much did you put in 25 000 yeah I had
like 25 Grand in it and so what's what's
that something is that a hundred I I
can't even do that is that I haven't
done the math at one point and this
wasn't the peak but at one point it was
like I would have had six million
dollars from that 25k it was like a
great Angel investment and again this
felt late like Tesla was already out
successful Elon Musk was a he's not what
he is today but he was a known person
right like I'm talking about this was
back in probably
2013-ish 2012 something like that dude
we should do another one of these
episodes because I think there's a lot
of great companies right now that
valuations are low where in 10 or 15
years when there's another great Market
things will be drastically different you
know this will be one of those things
where you're saying in 10 years you're
gonna wish you would have done what
we're suggesting
right and we should do another one we
should I I even had people build me like
a website for this like a sick looking
website I think we should do this me and
you I think should own a job board
called Sarah's list and we should just
keep this updated and what did you think
that I tweeted I tweeted out I was like
yeah like uh I think this is a great way
to make wealth where's like but like
researching these is a bit challenging
and that tweet got seen by millions not
millions of people hunt many hundreds of
thousands of people and a lot of really
good replies and there were some cool
things uh startups that were
mentioned and different job boards but
nothing where it's like perfect where
where I think it needs to be but yeah I
agree all right I think that's it that's
a wrap
[Music]